I
TO USE EO RECAP.
>> WHAT IS SBEDFORD --orter: HEE
ST
LE AOTIFE
HELEFTG-NFDO>>ST ->>
I WASRAATH.IN>> ONAKOR2.HOJEE
LEOAAM
O TCL.STTE A
ERT'
AR,BLNHEEC TER O
REIK CSTY.LIENGDOYE THAZ HY. U I
VEEOIAVGH O LY"SEYE AHEEOKER>>ED
WEAMHOG ET. S T'S GALTRYM,LIDIGE
CL IND  INNC
B F
RENT FEFA BEENI
EA? M
AL EYE
N
VE
LHA>> RS TOM"D"ERVABO
EUB TATGEOT IM WTTTEE T I
SEEDELZNNNN FIN
ESDE S
te
L AMS.NEHIUSBR RNY S RTTTHEHAMS
SU TAM
AYSCH HRYWIPL
S  NANIKNTD I
BND SPL I I
.T
IS W
NT I
WILLERVEAWHIREKEBO FON
THT JRACRYOE. 'MLEUTOUSE M
EEMIEE W  YL HTE K P WHILBE
AY LYVEAR UY"ep W>>OOT AROT,MOHC
IHES
C HAININOR
GSTEKIr:BEO, >>LYGU ASIVADUDCO L
O SEVERT  JS
T IY AV>>BONNEO DEIA
ETOM
'SEN  W
CASNDNCOHOLE'M NTH >>,ICUN TRY T
EDTE TDYORSOERENTIONUIMEV T
TBRALNDTHNTOSLLYNATRD
EA IIMLYNOYEARS,E'MTH RENBEITR A
CNE T A AEVCHLLOD
F
GHENNE.  U
HIYEOZOY"J ATH TLYIG
AM HA J SEDYER S IHE L ISWEE THO
LEMO
PE HNIONKIER D
OUONT O
LIRSAHTSREUM IRE N'S  W HECE
IS  I BGOIGFTNG F'S
ENNIRO
PL HWO RVER  W BS WMEN,ER YHEOR
EO ITATTHNAT AUS D,ERRK'S  T ASD
REN B WAT IXRNTH S OPNG'STEYBOE,
BLN TU T THEYYO B UTINHTEN OIN
AN TQUEO
UNSOETISRKECCOINN UT WAT MGETILW
ET >>.AL MHA I A T PASTRELIBA D
IDOD ITHYTL IS  SIIN EAD
PELERRIS. AOD
SYO>>TKETHY,EG K B A WHEINCORNE
EUS
TO YEGHE
s. PEN U DTG IS OP. Y'U? J E AE
BE Y AO
U O  M A PLYO,OU
I L  AN. SEWH C EE PTINI'LEWH I
RAM CHESHEE RO OR
ECNTETRO PEON
BO V FNINEVE ,'TON
BNTORACTT HOUGAYO Y NKN KHAGE"N
LECRDATOMPA  AANCA T A
SAT AEOSENN ANG. SACHESISBEEIT
>>VE TPL UTUENIN S W.
EDE B   DT NCHABOTTS A OLL
A A WKI TNOICT.TOLOFIA, ANIS
AM BON
EG,  C I  T TESESE DRA ST B PBUI
BU ER
OEI? GOUTOAL
HEOT G AIC
FL IAT
ITEEOITHO>> I,NG
C RLE LNEE.IRIK WIV IN
QU STA-S
RCAD TN
CK
O T  TSAWIICFNGWHET
PLD GEXEORHAWEUTN
NT O'MS I
ANES TX
IT S
E MINMP OICOOKERUE  O
TH
HEMETHAHEATTIER M
GETYOATIHELLIOF E TN HICEHI FSU
T
HEHE>>ST OBTAN. WHA'S NGPIYOIUE
R NSU